THIS IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM SERGEANTS AT
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLLAGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OKAY HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES JUNE CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES LAURA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LI LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
DONALD PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH STONE. TAGUE
GALLAGHER AS APPROVED LAW VOEPEL
WALDRON ARD WEBER WICKS WILSON
WOOD. MISTER SPEAKER.
YEAH.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK. OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
DOCTOR REGULAR. LET US BOW OUR
HEADS AND PRAY. DEAR HEAVENLY
FATHER TODAY LET US THINK ABOUT
THE POWER OF COMPASSION. IT IS
WITH THE JOYFUL HEART THAT I
SHARE GOOD NEWS. WE ARE NOW
EXTENDING FULL MEDICAL COVERAGE
TO ADULTS FIFTY YEARS OF AGE AND
OLDER REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IN OUR GOLDEN STATE ALL
ARE WELCOME AT GOD'S TABLE. LET
GRACE AND UNDERSTANDING GUIDE US
AS WE STRIVE TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF ALL WHO CALL OR GOLDEN
STATE HOME- ONLY WANT HAPPINESS
AND COMFORT FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR LOVED ONES. AND LET THAT
SAME BENEVOLENCE GUIDE OR
COLLEAGUES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
TO PASS IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR
THIS WOULD BE A TRUE AFFIRMATION
THAT ALL PEOPLE DESERVE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT. IN OUR GOLDEN STATE
WE PROUDLY STAND AS A BEACON OF
HOPE FOR SO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SEEKING OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
GREATEST STATE IN OUR NATION.
FOR HERE WE CELEBRATE THE RICH
DIVERSITY OF OUR PEOPLE AND OUR
DREAMS AND HERE. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO A BRIGHTER FUTURE THAT
EMBRACES EVERYONE FOR HERE. WE
HONOR. HUMANITY IN ALL ITS
GLORY. IN OUR LORD'S NAME WE
PRAY ON. THANK YOU DOT CURRICULA
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC. H. IT IS. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY
NINE TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE SOME
ABOUT AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
KELLY SAY ARE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTY SEVEN DISTRICT RESIDING
SEE FOLKS WHO PROPER PROTESTS
REFLECTED UPON READING LOCAL
ONES REYES MOVES AND MISTER
FLORA SECOND SET THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS.
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE. IN
AREF OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
SURGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE- TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. M. S.
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW SPEAKER RENDON TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ROBERT
RIVAS AND QUIRK-SILVA TO HAVE
GUESTS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AS
GUEST WILL BE SEATED AT HER
DESK. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE AB
TWENTY SIX OH SEVENTEEN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE.
ACR ONE EIGHTY TWO. EDUARDO
GARCIA FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX TO
WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BILLS
FROM APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND ORDER THEM TO THE SECOND
READING FILE THE BILLS ARE NOT
FISCAL AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE
WARD AND AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
NINE IS AREA. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GAS. REAR OF THE CHAMBER. ON
BEHALF. OF SPEAKER RENDON. WE
WELCOME A DELEGATION FROM THE
BAVARIAN STATE PARLIAMENT
INCLUDING DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL
ELENA SIMS. AND DOCTOR GIRL HARD
WASH LEARN. WHO IS THE HEAD OF
THE DELEGATION PROFESSOR DR GER
HARD WASH THERE THE VERY- IS THE
LARGEST FEDERAL STATE OF GERMANY
LET'S WELCOME THEM TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE MOVING T BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING. THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
233-816-5716 581-832-2520 SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY THREE OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY ONE FORTY WITH
MINUTES. TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN TO
THE BUSINESS TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY TO MEET
WITH THE PARENTS SIXTEEN FIFTY
FOUR THE MEMBERS NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS TWO
THOUSAND TO THE MINISTRY FIVE
ANY SETTLEMENTS TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE MINUTES TWENTY SIX
SIXTY NINE WITH A MYSTERY THREE
SEVENTY SIX THE MEMBERS TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR MINUTES. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SIX OF THE VENICE
ONE THIRTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY THREE TO THIRTY FOUR
MINUTES TWENTY WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MINISTRY AND I FORTY FOUR
MINUTES SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
WITH EVENTS. NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY ONE
SIXTEEN WITH A BETTER IS TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR THE MEMBERS
TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY TO SIX OF THE%
MEMBERS TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS. TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR MINUTES TWENTY THREE
THIRTY NINE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY MINUTES TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
SIX OF THE VENICE TWENTY SEVEN
OH TO THE MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE OF THEM IS. NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR THE MEMBERS TWENTY
FIVE BY THE ABLE TO MEMBERS
TWENTY NINETEEN WITH A MEMBERS
23-14 WITH HIS TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED M. S. TWENTY SEVEN THREE
WOMEN AT SEVENTY FORTY ONE
TWENTY NINE SIXTY NINE AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO ELEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS WITH.
READ AND ALL. AMENDMENTS DEEMED.
A MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY NINE. H. R. ONE OH FOUR
SANTIAGO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD READING THE CLERK WILL
READ POSTPOSITION ONE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO SINGLE
TOMORROW WEEK. MR SANTIAGO HE
MAILED I THANK HIM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE OH FOUR.
IN WHICH WE CELEBRATE SINGLE
MILE. I RISE AS A AS A KID OF A
MEXICAN IMMIGRANT. I OR MY DAD
CAME TO THE COUNTRY UNDOCUMENTED
AT A YOUNG AGE OF A TEENAGER.
AND IT'S NOT A STORY THIS UNIQUE
TO ME MANY OF US HAVE. GONE
THROUGH THIS OR HAVE A SIMILAR
STORY IN IN OUR HISTORY. OUR
PARENTS CAME AT A VERY YOUNG
AGE. WOULD NOT A SINGLE DOLLAR
IN THEIR HAND. AND LESS THAN
CARRYING A BAG. BUT THEY HAVE
HOPES THAT THIS WOULD. GIVE THEM
THAT AMERICAN DREAM THAT THEY
COULD RAISE A BETTER FAN THE
TICKET REYES OF A FAMILY AND A
BETTER FUTURE THAN THEY HAD AT
HOME. IN WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT. THE ROOM AROUND US. THE
GROWTH IN THE LATINO CAUCUS. THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED
THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WE COME
FROM AND THE THINGS THAT WE
FIGHT FOR. AND THE WORK AHEAD OF
US. IT'S WITHOUT PRIDE IN MY
HEART THAT I STAND TODAY. TO
PREVENT THIS RESOLUTION. IT'S A
HOLIDAY WERE MILLIONS OF MEXICAN
AMERICANS AND. AND OUR LARGER
LATINO CULTURE COME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE. BUT IT'S MORE THAN
JUST A BEER DRINKER MARGARITA.
IT IT'S WE CELEBRATED ON IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO. THE
UNDERMINE THE A MEXICAN FORCES
DEFEATED THE FRENCH ARMY UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF A NOT SO
SARGODHA AND ETERNAL PUEBLA
WHILE THEY WERE OUTNUMBERED AND
THEY HAD LIMITED RESOURCES. WE
DON'T ONLY CELEBRATE. OUR
HISTORY TODAY WE CELEBRATE EVERY
PERSON. EVERYWOMAN EVERY MAN AND
EVERY CHILD WHO MADE THAT HAPPEN. AND IT ALSO COMES WITH A BIG
RESPONSIBILITY. YES WE RECOGNIZE
THE WORK THAT WE DO IN OUR
COLLEAGUE EARLIER SAID THAT
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE UNDOCK
AND UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. GET
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. BUT THE
AGE OF FIFTY BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF
SPONSOR ABILITY THAT MUCH WORK
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. LIKE THAT GAP
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVEN. AND FORTY
NINE IT'S STILL NEEDS THAT
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. WHETHER
YOU'RE DOCUMENTED OR NOT. WHAT
WE FIGHT FOR. COME TO THE
RESPONSIBLE UNDERSTAND. THAT
WE'RE GONNA FIGHT FOR. A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM WE HAVE TODAY
IS BROKEN AND IT'S LEAVING MANY
OF OUR CULTURE AND ALL PEOPLES
BEHIND. WELL PROUD THE BLOOD YOU
KNOW CAUCUSES GROWN. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE A U. S.
SENATOR WHO IS LATINO. AND ONE
DAY YES WE WILL HAVE A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WITH LATINO
OR LATINA. WE ACKNOWLEDGE
OUTSTANDING LATINOS. WHO
REPRESENT OUR VOICES. IN THESE
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS I WILL
NEVER FORGET THE VERY MANY WHO
FOUGHT HARD. IT MADE THESE PAST
POSSIBLE FOR US AND FOR OTHERS
IN THE FUTURE. TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF
ESSENTIAL LATINO WORKERS. WHO
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC
PROVIDING FOOD MEDICAL SERVICES
. IT KEPT OUR STATE RUNNING. WE
CELEBRATE SINGLE TAMAYO. WE ASK
YOU TO CELEBRATE WITH US. AND
HELP US TO HONOR ALL THOSE ALL
THOSE WHO WERE UNRECOGNIZED
HEROES. HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST. AND MANY OF YOU WHO
ARE UNLOCKING THE DOORS TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS. IN THERE
THERE'S ALSO THOSE OTHER PEOPLE
THEM TIMES THAT ARE INVISIBLE.
LIKE MY MOM WHO CLEAN HOMES. MY
DAD WHO WAITED TABLES. MANY
FARMWORKERS WHO ARE OUT ON THE
FIELD EVERY SINGLE DAY. WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
SEE THOSE HARD WORKING PEOPLE.
THANK THEM. WHETHER THEIR
DOCUMENTARY DOCUMENT. IT'S WHAT
WE BELIEVE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
MAKING CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. I WOULD ARGUE WE ARGUE
THAT WE PLAYED A CENTRAL ROLE IN
THAT. WITH THAT RESPONSIBILITY
AS I SAID. WHAT THAT HONOR COMES
GREAT WORK THAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT A
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE OF FOR AN
ASSET THE FIRST ROLLED BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO.
MR BONTA S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE OH FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZES SINGLE TAMAYO THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY IS PROUD TO HAVE
A LONG HISTORY OF WORKING WITH
THE LATINO COMMUNITY TO BATTLE
LONGSTANDING INJUSTICES. WE HAVE
SEEN LEADERS THAT STAND AT THE
INTERSECTION ABOUT THE L. G. B.
T. Q. AND NOT THEY DON'T
COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER TO
LEADER COMMUNITIES AND MAKE
GREAT STRIDES TOWARD EQUALITY
AND INCLUSION. THESE INCLUDE
LATINO G. B. T. Q. LEADERS LIKE
SYLVIA AT THE VET I WHO IS ONE
OF THE EARLIEST PIONEERS IN
SUPPORTING THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY IN NEW YORK CITY IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. DENNIS
THE LEON WAS A HUMAN IGHTS
ATTORNEY WHO BECAME PRESIDENT OF
THE LATINO COMMISSION ON AIDS
HELPING SPREAD INFORMATION ON
THE AIDS EPIDEMIC INTO THE
LATINO COMMUNITY. HE WAS ALSO
ONE OF THE FIRST PUBLIC
OFFICIALS TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
HIS STATUS AS HAVING HIV AND IT
OP ED IN THE NEW YORK TIMES. OR
GLORIA- UNDER LULA WHO WAS A-CHICANA PROFESSOR AUTHOR WHO
WROTE THE GROUND BREAKING WORK.
THEN YOU MUST DECIDE AND
INTERSECTIONAL EXPLORATION OF
FEMALE LEVINE ON QUEER
IDENTITIES AND AMERICAN BORDER
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE BUT A FEW
OF THE LATINO LGBTQ LEADERS WHO
HAVE HELPED BRING US TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE LGBTQ CAUCUS WE WANT TO
CONGRATULATE AND RECOGNIZE THE
AMAZING WORK OF THE RECIPIENTS
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO LETTING
US AWARDS THEIR DEDICATION TO
WORK FOR THE COMMUNITY IS TRULY
AN INSPIRATION FOR ALL.
COLLEAGUES FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU TO JOIN
US IN SUPPORTING HR WHEN- FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER FANTASTIC MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HR ONE OF FOUR
IN JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
. RECOGNIZE THE INCREDIBLE
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
AND RESILIENCE OF OUR LATINO.
COMMUNITY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
CONTRIBUTED. MAGNIFICENTLY IN SO
MANY FIELDS TO THE STATE AND
EVEN BEFORE WE WERE STATE IN
CULTURE AND IN BUSINESS AND
SCIENCE AND ART AND
ENTERTAINMENT IN SPORTS- AND
ALSO IN THE FIGHT FOR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE THE FIGHT FOR
WORKERS RIGHTS THE FIGHT TO
STAND UP. FOR PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THIS STATE RUN WE KNOW THAT OUR
LATINO COMMUNITY AND LATINO
LEADERS HAVE BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF ALL OF THAT. AND I
KNOW THAT OUR JEWISH CAUCUS IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
STATE FEELS A VERY STRONG SENSE
OF SOLIDARITY AND KINSHIP WITH
OUR LATINO COMMUNITY. WHETHER
IT'S OUR SHARED HISTORY OF
IMMIGRATION IN THE SHARED
STRUGGLES WE'VE HAD. AS PEOPLE
THAT HAVE COME TO THE STATE IN
SEARCH OF OPPORTUNITY FLEEING
PERSECUTION WHETHER IT'S THE
SHARED VALUES OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY AND HARD WORK OUR OUR
JEWISH COMMUNITY HERE. CHAU
ADMIRES AND APPRECIATES THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE LATINO COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND OF
COURSE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY. THE
MOST RECENT STUDY SUGGESTS 5% OF
JEWS THE UNITED STATES ARE ALSO
LET YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE. SOME
PROMINENT EXAMPLES OF THIS
WHETHER THIS IS OUR MAYOR IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ERIC
GARCETTI. ARE DHS SECRETARY A
HUNDRED MY YOUR KISS. OR PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONTRIBUTING IN OTHER
WAYS LIKE DON FRANCISCO. OR
DAVID BLAINE SO WE- WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY CONNECTED AND INDEED WE
ARE FAMILY. MOST SOME OF THE
MOST RECENT RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT 25% OF LATINOS. HAVE
SIGNIFICANT STRANDS OF JEWISH
DNA BECAUSE OF OUR SHARED
HISTORY. OF IMMIGRATION TO THE
NEW WORLD SO ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS. IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY ONE OF FIRST APPLIED-
THE MEMBERS OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
WHOSE STORIES ARE SO
INSPIRATIONAL. AND TO- ABLY
REPRESENT AND SERVE. IN THIS
BODY AND ALSO TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIONS. OF OUR
HONOREES TODAY SO ON BEHALF OF.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS. URGED WITH OUR
STRONG SUPPORT AYE VOTE ON HR
ONE OF FOUR. THANK YOU MISTY
REAL MISS QUIRK-SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
CINCO DE MAYO WEEK. H. R. ONE O.
FOUR DECLARES THIS WEEK CINCO DE
MAYO WEEK WHICH OFFERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
COURAGE AND ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
MEXICAN FORCES AT WAY BELOW AND
LATINOS HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO ALL
FACETS OF A COMMUNITY. AND- JUST
STEP OUT OF MY REMARKS AND REFER
TO LATINOS WE KNOW IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY THAT LATINOS ARE SOME
OF THE HARDEST WORKING WOMEN WE
KNOW THAT FOR MANY OF THEM
FAMILY AND FAITH IS AT THE CORE
OF THEIR VALUES AND WHEN WE
REFER TO LIVE FIFTEEN AS WE
OFTEN REFER TO THEM. AS FEARS.
THE CELEBRATION OF CINCO DE MAYA
WAS CREATED BY LUCY LATINOS
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA DURING THE
EARLY DAYS OF AMERICA. THIS WAS%
THE PERIOD OF THE CIVIL WAR. AND
LATINOS WANTED TO SHOW WHERE
THEY STOOD ON THE ISSUES OFTHAT
GREAT CONFLICT AT THAT TIME
LATINOS OPPOSE SLAVERY AND
SUPPORTED FREEDOM AND RACIAL
EQUALITY. THE MEXICAN VICTORY
OVER THE MONARCHS TROOPS AT THE
BATTLE OF WAY BELOW ON SINGLE
DAY MILE OF EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
ENERGIZED LATINOS AND CALIFORNIA
TO INCREASE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
LINCOLN AS WELL AS WAR AS- EVERY
SINGLE DAY MILE DURING THE CIVIL
WAR AND FRENCH INTERVENTION.
INTERVENTION LATINOS IN
CALIFORNIA MARCH BE HÌNH BOTH
THE UNITED STATES AND MEXICAN
FLAGS THEY SPEND THEY SAYING
WHEN JOHNNY COMES MARCHING HOME
AGAIN AND ADIOS MAMA CARLOTA.
THEY GAVE SPEECHES IN BOTH
SPANISH AND ENGLISH TO SUPPORT
LINCOLN'S IDEA OF GOVERNMENT OF
THE PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE AND FOR
THE PEOPLE WE HEAR IN THE STATE
CAPITAL CONTINUE THAT TRADITION
BY CELEBRATING CINCO DE MAYO AS
A TIME FOR LATINOS TO
DEMONSTRATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND FOR THE IDEALS OF
FREEDOM AND EQUALITY AROUND THE
WORLD. CINCO DE MAYA REMINDS US
THAT THE FOUNDATION OF ANY
NATION AND OUR STATE IS ITS
PEOPLE FOR THESE REASONS I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE JOIN THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR ONE OH FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT. OF HR ONE OH FOUR
SANTIAGO. YOU KNOW FOR SO MANY
DECADES AND GENERATIONS. THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THE
LATINO COMMUNITY HAVE PARALLELED
AND OUR STRIFE IN THE CHALLENGE
TO. SIX UPWARD MOBILITY AWAY
FROM HOMELAND BUT IN A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE UNITED AS ONE.
POLICIES AND ACTIONS NOT ALWAYS
LINING UP. WITH THOSE DESIRES
EIGHTIES THAT AREN'T RECEIVING
ALWAYS THE FAIRNESS AND EQUITY
OF RESOURCES TO FIND THE PLAYING
FIELD TRULY LEVEL. BUT WE
CELEBRATE THE STRONG
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THOSE FROM
THE LATINO COMMUNITY. WHO HAVE
PERSEVERED AND PRESS THROUGH
NOTWITHSTANDING WE FIGHT FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE ON BOARDS
RIFAI FOR OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EQUITY IN EDUCATION. WE FIGHT
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE SAFETY
IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL RESPECTING EACH
OTHER'S POINT OF VIEW HERITAGE.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE. SO
WE SHARE THIS AS AN ACRONYM
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY A
LATINO COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE ARE
SO OFTEN TIMES NEIGHBORS LIVING
NEXT TO EACH OTHER. EDUCATING
OUR KIDS IN THE SAME SYSTEM.
FIND IN OUR OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR KIDS TO
BE ABLE TO STAY IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS FIGHTING
GENTRIFICATION AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AFFRONT MANY OF US WHO GREW
UP TOGETHER SEEN CHANGE HAPPEN
AND SOMEHOW WE'RE LOSING OUT. ON
THE FUTURE. BUT IT COMES FROM
THIS RESILIENCE. OF HISTORY AND
HERITAGE IS WHAT WE CELEBRATE
TODAY. PEOPLE WHO HAVE FOUGHT
AND HAVE MADE SURE THAT THEY
WERE NOT ONLY FIGHTING FOR THE
PRESENT DAY BUT ALSO FOR THE
FUTURE AND FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AND SO ON BEHALF OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND THE
CAUCUS. AND CERTAINLY LOOKING AT
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SERVICE
CHÁVEZ AND DR KING AND WHAT THEY
STOOD FOR AND EACH OF OUR
RESPECTIVE HISTORIES. AND HOW
THAT SORT OF LAID A FOUNDATION
FOR HOW WE WOULD BE LEGISLATORS
TODAY. AND TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THE VALUES OF EACH
OTHER. NOT JUST BETWEEN OUR TWO
COMMUNITIES BUT BETWEEN ALL OF
US AS ONE CALIFORNIA. SO WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS CONGRATULATE THE
HONOREES TODAY- SAY THANK YOU TO
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WHO. WE WORK TO
SUPPORT YOUR GOALS YOUR GOALS
ARE OUR GOALS. YES VOTE ON HR
ONE OH FOUR. THANK YOU MISS
HOLDEN AND HIS FELLOW THERE'S
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I AM TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR WHEN I WON.
LATINAS ARE DIVERSE WE COME IN
ALL SHAPES ALL SIZES ALL COLORS
ALL FAITHS BACKGROUNDS EVEN ALL
POLITICAL SPECTRUMS AND I RISE
TODAY. BECAUSE I AM THE ONLY
LATINO MEMBER OF THE GOP. AND I
GUARANTEE THAT YOU WILL SEE ME
CONTINUE TO WORK ON FORWARDING
AND ADVANCING THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND ENSURING THAT THEY
ARE AT EVERY TABLE BECAUSE WE
ONLY MOVE FORWARD WHEN WE ARE
ALL TABLES WHEN WE ARE AT
DEMOCRAT TABLES WHEN WE ARE AT
REPUBLICAN TABLES WHEN WE ARE
BOARDROOM TABLES WHEN WE ARE AT
KITCHEN TABLES. I'M EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND TO
BE A CONSERVATIVE VOICE FOR THE
MANY CONSERVATIVE OF THE NO
VOICES THAT FEEL THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A VOICE AND I AM PROUD TO
CARRY THAT BANNER AND TO WORK TO
ENSURING THAT WE CONTINUE THE
GREAT SUCCESS OF THIS WONDERFUL
STATE THAT MY FAMILY CAME TO
HEAR THE NINETEEN ELEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN. FROM MEXICO
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM X. STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AND MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HR ONE OH FOUR. AND I THINK
AT THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY WE ARE
REMINDED. OF HOW PRECIOUS. THE
DETERMINATION OF A PEOPLE TO
FURTHER THEIR WELL BEING THROUGH
CONCERTED EFFORT AGAINST ALL
ODDS IS WE SEE THIS PLAYING OUT
. IN UKRAINE TODAY. I THINK IT
IS SO VITAL THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THESE MOMENTS AND PERMISSION TO
READ. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
FAMILIAR WORDS FROM JOHN DONE IN
HONOR OF THIS DAY. NO MAN IS AN
ISLAND ENTIRE OF ITSELF. EVERY
MAN IS A PIECE OF THE CONTINENT
A PART OF THE MAIN. IF A CLOUD
BE WASHED AWAY BY THE SEA EUROPE
IS THE LESSE. AS WELL AS A PRE
PROMONTORY WERE AS WELL AS A FOR
MANOR OF THY FRIENDS OR OF THINE
OWN WERE. ANY MAN'S DEATH
DIMINISHES ME. BECAUSE I AM
INVOLVED IN MANKIND. AND
THEREFORE NEVER SEND TO KNOW FOR
WHOM THE BELL TOLLS IT TOLLS FOR
THEE. I THINK THIS RESOLUTION IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY. NOT JUST FOR
THE- RETROSPECTIVE LOOK BUT FOR
THE CONTEMPORARY LOOK IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENCOURAGING.
DETERMINED PURSUIT OF A BETTER
LIFE FOR EVERY INDIVIDUAL AND
I'M GRATEFUL THAT IS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU MISS COOLEY.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE ITEM. MR
SANTIAGO SAYS OF THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. WELL. CLOSER ALL THERE
ARE FIFTY NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED
. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY IN HONOR OF THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS. THE
MEMBERS WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
SELECTED TO BE IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER MAY MOVE TO THE BACK
NOW. EVERYONE ELSE PLEASE REMAIN
SEATED FOR THE DURATION OF THE
CEREMONY. TO OUR STEAM GAS AS
YOUR NAME IS RED PLEASE COME TO
THE REAR SENSOR CENTER I'LL TO
BE RECOGNIZED. AND THE CLERK.
WILL READ. THE HONOREE FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN PUBLIC SERVICE IS
IRENE TOVAR I READ SO FAR
MISSION HILLS IS A CHICANA
ACTIVIST WHO WAS PART OF THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT WORKING WITH
SAYS OUR SHOPPERS AND THE LOWER
SERICA MISTER WALKER WAS ALSO
ACTIVE IN THE CHICANO MORATORIUM
COMMITTEE TO PROTEST THE
INJUSTICES THAT CHICANO SPACE
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR MR OF OUR
WORK IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN AS
AN ASSISTANT. TO EXPEDITE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES WHERE SHE
ORGANIZED A STATEWIDE CHICANOS
ISSUES CONFERENCE EVENTS SERVED
EIGHT YEARS AS THE FIRST MEXICAN
AMERICAN APPOINTED TO THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN IMPLEMENTING
DIFFERENTIAL PLAYING AND
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WHICH REMOVED
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS IN THE STATE
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM SHE
SUBSEQUENTLY SERVING THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WAS SO FAR
HAS SERVED AS THE CEO OF THE
LATIN AMERICAN CIVIC ASSOCIATION
PLEASE WELCOME I RENTAL CAR.
THE ANA REPORTS EVEN IN
JOURNALISM AND MEDIA IS GENERAL
CONTRARIS. JENNA CONTRARIS OF
LOS ANGELES. IS AN AWARD WINNING
FILMMAKER WHO BELIEVE STORY
TELLING IS MORE THAN JUST
CAPTURING AN AUDIENCE THIS
CONTRASTS USES ESPN AND ITS
MULTIPLE OUTLETS TO ILLUMINATE
IMPORTANT ISSUES SUCH AS SOCIAL
JUSTICE EQUALITY AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION SINCE STARTING AT
ESPN IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
MISS CONTRARIS IS BECOME A ONE
TIME EMMY AWARD WINNER FIVE TIME
EMMY NOMINEE A TWO TIME NEW YORK
FESTIVAL SILVER MEDAL RECIPIENT.
PLEASE WELCOME JENNA CONTRARIS.
OUR NEXT HONOREE IS ALFRED DS
AND PHONTE WHO WAS REMEMBERED IN
MEMORIAM AND REPRESENTED TODAY
BY HIS WIFE ELVIRA D. AZ
INVOLUNTARY AND HIS DAUGHTER
KARINA NAVA. ALFRED D. AS IN
PHONTE OF SALINAS WAS PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE COMMUNITY HOUSING
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS AND PLANNING
ASSOCIATION MONTEREY COUNTY'S
LARGEST NONPROFIT HOUSING
ORGANIZATION. UNDER MISTER DÍAS
EN FONT IS TWENTY THREE YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP CHESBRO BUILT AND
RENOVATED 200-040-0407 SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AND APARTMENTS FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES
AND MONTEREY SAN BENITO AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES. HE ALSO
GUIDED EFFORTS TO BOLSTER ACCESS
TO EDUCATION TO RESIDENTS BY
ESTABLISHING THREE COLLEGE%
SCHOLARSHIPS MISTER DÍAS EN
FRANCAIS BECAME ONE OF THE
REASONS GOALS RECOGNIZED LEADERS
AND ADVOCATED FOR FARMWORKER AND
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. SERVING ON
NUMEROUS BOARDS ACROSS THE
REGION HE IS SURVIVED BY ELVIRA
HIS WIFE FOR THIRTY ONE YEARS
THREE CHILDREN KARINA ALEXIS AND
MARCOS IN GRANDSON LEO PLEASE
WELCOME AND BAR ELVIRA D. AZ AND
FONTAINE AND KARINA NAVA. ON
BEHALF OF ALL FOR THE S. AND
FUNDED.
THE ON A REPORT SHE'D BEEN IN
PUBLIC SERVICE IS RON HERRERA.
JOHN HERRERA OF LONG BEACH HAS
BEEN A UNION MEMBER FOR OVER
FORTY ONE YEARS AND CURRENTLY
SERVES AS PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. HE STARTED HIS UNION
CAREER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
AS A PACKAGE CAR DRIVER WITH THE
UNITED PARCEL SERVICE WHERE HE
REPRESENTED HIS FELLOW MEMBERS
AS A UPS SHOP STEWARD IN TWO
THOUSAND MISTER FOREVER WAS
HIRED AS THE TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THREE NINETY SIX BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE AND IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE HE BECAME THE
PRESIDENT OF LOCAL THREE NINETY
SIX. IN TWO THOUSAND THREE HE
WAS ELECTED TO THE PRINCIPAL
OFFICER POSITION AS SECRETARY
TREASURER OF LOCAL THREE NINETY
SIX A POSITION HE CURRENTLY
HOLDS TODAY PLEASE WELCOME RON
HERRERA.
THE HONOREE FOR ACHIEVEMENT IN
BUSINESS AND PHILANTHROPY IS
GEORGE PLAZA. GEORGE PLOT OF
NEWPORT BEACH IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
PHILANTHROPIST AUTHOR AND
FOUNDER AND CEO OF CORDOVA
CORPORATION A FULL SERVICE
ENGINEERING FIRM THAT
SPECIALIZES IN THE DELIVERY OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION WATER
AND ENERGY SECTORS MISTER PLIES
A GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LOS ANGELES
MEMORIAL COLISEUM COMMISSION. HE
SERVES AS A MEMBER OF THE
PROGRAM ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
STANFORD UNIVERSITY'S
CONSTRUCTION INSTITUTE AND AS A
PRESIDENTIAL ASSOCIATE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HE IS THE CO AUTHOR
OF AFFIRMATIVE BOOK ON LATINO
POLITICS POWERSHIFT HOW LATINOS
IN CALIFORNIA TRAMS WILL
TRANSFORM POLITICS IN AMERICA
WHICH CHRONICLES THE DEVELOPMENT
OF LATINO POLITICAL EMPOWERMENT.
INSPIRING JOURNEYS OF TEN
TRAILBLAZING LATINO LEADERS
PLEASE WELCOME GEORGE BLAHA.
BE ON A REPORT SHE'D BEEN IN
BUSINESS IS MARIA SALINAS. REAR
SALINAS OF PASADENA IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE FIRST WOMAN AND LATINA
TO HOLD TO LEAVE THE CHAMBER IN
ITS ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YEAR
HISTORY. MISCELLANEOUS IS AN
APPOINTEE TO GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM'S COMMISSION ON THE
FUTURE OF WORK AND WAS NAMED TO
HIS BUSINESS AND JOBS RECOVERY
TASK FORCE SHE SERVES ON THE U.
S. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE COMMITTEE
OF ONE HUNDRED THE COALITION OF
REGIONAL ECONOMIC ASSOCIATION
LEADERS. IS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF MOBILITY
TWENTY ONE AND SERVES AS AN
APPOINTEE OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI TO THE MAX LA
COMMISSION A FOREIGN POLICY
INITIATIVE BETWEEN MEXICO AND
LOS ANGELES PLEASE WELCOME MARIA
SALINAS.
GOT A REPORT SHE EVEN AND HEALTH
AND SCIENCES DR CLERMONT
VALENZUELA. DR RELATABLE
VALENZUELA OF REDLANDS IS A
NATIVE OF SHELLING. IN AN OBGYN
PHYSICIAN WHO BUILT A WOMEN'S
HEALTH DEPARTMENT THAT SERVES
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY SPORTS
RESIDENTS. A LIFELONG LEARNER DR
FELONS WELL COMPLETED TWO
FELLOWSHIPS AND EARNED AN MBA
LATER IN LIFE WHILE PRACTICING
MEDICINE FULL TIME. DOCTOR
FELONS WHETHER CURRENTLY OWNS
SEVEN CLINICS WERE TWENTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES RECEIVE CARE
FOR PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
NEEDS. HE FOUNDED THE VALENZUELA
FAMILY FOUNDATION AND HISPANIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND RESEARCH THAT
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF DIVERSE
POPULATIONS PLEASE WELCOME
DOCTOR PALERMO VALENZUELA.
OUR NEXT HONOREE AS CHEECH MARIN
SPECIAL GUEST IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN LATINO SPIRIT AWARD
HONOREE. CHICHERIN OF JOSHUA
TREE IS AN ACTOR DIRECTOR WRITER
MUSICIAN ART COLLECTOR AND
HUMANITARIAN ASIDE FROM CHEESES
IMPRESSIVE FILM CAREER HE HAS
ALSO RECOGNIZED TODAY AS THE
PREEMINENT CHICANO ART ADVOCATE.
MISTER MORAN HAS ENTERED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE AND THE RIVERSIDE ART
MUSEUM TO CREATE THE MARIN
CENTER FOR CHICANO ART CULTURE
AND INDUSTRY. SLATED TO OPEN
NEXT MONTH WITH CHEECH WILL
BECOME A PERMANENT HOME FOR HIS
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED WORKS.
OF CHICANO ART INCLUDING
PAINTINGS SCULPTURES AND
PHOTOGRAPHY COLLECTIVELY THE
MOST RENOWNED TO COME TO ART
COLLECTION IN THE UNITED STATES
PLEASE WELCOME CHEECH MARIN.
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY'S
CEREMONY AS THE HONOREE FOR
CHEAPER THAN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT SONIA MANZANO. SO
YOU'RE MANZANO IS A FIRST
GENERATION MAINLINE MAINLAND
PORTER RICAN RAISED IN SOUTH
BRONX. SHE PLAYED THE ROLE OF
MARIA ON SESAME STREET AND
RECEIVED A LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT
AWARD FOR HER WORK ON THE SHOW.
MANZANO HAS ALSO RECEIVED
FIFTEEN IN THESE FORSTAFF
WRITING SESAME STREET THE
CONGRESSIONAL HISPANIC CAUCUS
AWARD M. HISPANIC HERITAGE AWARD
FOR EDUCATION AND IS AN AWARD
WINNING CHILDREN'S BOOK AUTHOR
SHE'S ALL SHE ALSO CREATED AN
ANIMATED SERIES CALLED. ALMOST
WAY. ALSO WHEN ABLE TO ATTEND
TODAY CEREMONIES THE HONOREE FOR
CHEAP IN AND COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT ALPHONSE OPENS OWN
PHD. DR ALPHONSE OPEN DON'T HAS
OVER TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
WORKING IN THE COUNSELING FIELD
IN TEN YEARS AS A PARENT AND
ADVOCATE FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS. HE'S A SUBSTITUTE
ABUSE COUNSELOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE DIRECTOR AND NOW WE
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE. DR
PETRONE BEGIN PARENT ADVOCACY
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WITH THE
INTENTION OF HELPING LATINO
PARENTS OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES NAVIGATE THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM. DR DON'T HAS MANAGED TO
ACQUIRE THOUSANDS OF SERVICES
FOR STUDENTS INCLUDING TUTORING
PHYSICAL THERAPY NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS. MEMBERS
AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING ALL OF OUR HONOREES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS. YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
AND MISSED REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN ACR ONE FIFTEEN NGUYEN
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN H. TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
TO HAVE GUESTS SEATED AT HER
DESK. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A GUEST SAID AS
JOINED US ON THE FLOOR MR VINE
TESTS'S SISTER RIVERSIDE
COUNCILMEMBER CLARISSA CERVANTES
HAS JOINED US THIS WALKING HER
DECEMBER.
MEMBERS WE ARE. RETURN TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS FIFTY FIVE.
THROUGH. SIXTY SEVEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE. AND THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS I THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
THE SUNSET ON A CAP ON RETAIN
EDGE FOR PUBLIC WORKS
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. WHEN
PUBLIC AGENCIES WORK WITH
CONTRACTORS ON CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THEY KEEP A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY CALLED RETAIN
EDGE UNTIL FULL COMPLETION OF
THE PROJECT IN TWENTY ELEVEN SB
TWO NINETY THREE LIMITED THE
AMOUNT OF RETENTION TO NO MORE
THAN 5% WITH A SUNSET THIS
SUNSET HAS SINCE BEEN EXTENDED
TWICE AND THIS BILL WOULD MAKE A
LOT PERMANENT. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND I
HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE IT. THANK YOU
MISS PEACH NORRIS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON THE ITEM
GLOBAL ROLE. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN
ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AND SEVENTY
. THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
COOKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE ACCOLADES
COMMUNICATIONS MR LEVINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC ACCESS
ACCESS CHANNELS THAT ARE
PRODUCED IN HIGH DEFINITION BE
BROADCAST IN HIGH DEFINITION BY
OUR LOCAL CABLE PROVIDERS SINCE
PASSAGE OF THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OR DIFFICULT AS
WE CALL IT IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
TELEVISIONS COMPUTERS AND EVEN
OUR CELL PHONES HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES ALLOWING US ALL TO SEE
HIGHER QUALITY BROADCASTS OF OUR
FAVORITE STREAMING SHOWS IN A
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AT
WORK PUBLIC ACCESS CHANNELS THAT
PRODUCE STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROCEEDINGS INCLUDING TODAY'S
FLOOR SESSION HAVE ALSO SEEN
GREAT. TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES
BIG CAMERAS IN THIS CHAMBER AND
IN OUR LEGISLATIVE HEARING ROOMS
PRODUCE STATE LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS IN HD. CABLE
PROVIDERS CAN INTENTIONALLY
DOWNGRADE THE SIGNAL RESULTING
IN LOW QUALITY BROADCASTS THAT
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
PUBLIC TO SEE AND UNDERSTAND THE
WORK OF ITS GOVERNMENT AND
HAPPENS TO OUR LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS TO. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE DOES NOT INCREASE
COSTS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PRODUCE PUBLIC ACCESS CONTENT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
GOVERNMENTAL EDUCATIONAL AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMMING IS ALREADY
PRODUCED IN HD. THIS WILL ONLY
COURT REQUIRES THAT PUBLIC
ACCESS CONTENT PRODUCED IN HD
NOT BE DOWNGRADED TO A LOWER
TRANSMISSION STANDARD MAKING IT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO RE
PRESENTATIONS. MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
ACCESS CHANNELS ARE PRODUCED IN
HD THEY SHOULD BE BROADCAST IN
HD. SO SMILE MEMBERS YOUR ON
CAMERA JOHN H. D. CAMERA LET US
ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO SEE THEIR
GOVERNMENT AT WORK WITH THE SAME
QUALITY THAT THEY WATCH SPORTS
MOVIES AND ALL OTHER PROGRAMMING
IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
A FULLY TRANSPARENT. AND HIGH
DEFINITION FUTURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MR LEVINE. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK OF THE
ROLE. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS FOLKS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MICHELLE OF EMAILS CALL.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO BY MS
BERHARAP COOKERY. SOME PEOPLE
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND
OTHERS MACKLIN THE PUBLIC
SWIMMING POOLS MISPRINT OR BATH
. YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE U. S. L.
A. CERTIFIED OCEAN LIFEGUARDS
DRIVER. TO PROVIDE SERVICES AT
UNDERSTAFFED CITY POOLS PROVIDED
THEY RECEIVE ALL THE PROPER
CROSSOVER TRAINING BY NATIONALLY
CERTIFIED PERSONNEL THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR HAVE A- THANK YOU
MS PER ORDER. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLARK LIBERAL.
CEREMONIAL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF AN ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS AND RETAIN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE THROUGH SEVENTY
SIX PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN PASS RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS SEVENTY EIGHT
THROUGH EIGHTY TWO. THAT BRINGS
US FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE. AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
IMMACULATELY TO COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT. DR CHECK YOU MAILED
. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHEN. SEEING
ABSOLUTELY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN ALL.
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUT
OF THEM. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF ICE FIFTY THREE NINE
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN A FILE AN
EIGHTY FIVE. PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX.
WILL PASS. SEVEN CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBERS SAY AUTO AND
OTHER NOT GOING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES SUMMER SORRY THE OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
EMERGENCY POWERS EXISTS TO ORDER
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE STATE TO
RESPOND IN A TIMELY AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER TO AN EMINENT
CRISIS. UNDER EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW THE CALIFORNIA
URGENCY SERVICES ACT AUTHORIZES
THE GOVERNOR TO SUSPEND ANY
REGULATION OR STATUTE DURING A
STATIC STATE OF EMERGENCY THESE
POWERS ARE AUTHORIZED UPON THE
DECLARATION OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND REMAIN IN EFFECT
THROUGH THE END OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. HOWEVER AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY LIMIT EMERGENCY
POWERS IT OPERATES UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THESE EMERGENCY
POWERS WILL ONLY BE EXERCISED TO
RESPOND TO CONDITIONS RELATING
TO THE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWENTY SIX
OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
RANGING FROM NEW YORK TO ALASKA
THAT HAVE EXPLICITLY SPECIFIED
THAT EMERGENCY POWERS MUST BE
USED TO RESPONSIVELY TO
CONDITIONS RELATED TO THAT
EMERGENCY. OF THE TWENTY FOUR
OTHER STATES THAT DO NOT HAVE
THIS CLAUSE IN THE EMERGENCY
POWER STATUE THERE FIFTEEN
STATES THAT DO NOT ALLOW THE
GOVERNOR TO CHANGE STATUTES AT
ALL DURING EMERGENCY. A CLEAR
MINORITY OF A MERE NINE STATES
HAVE NO CLEAR FINE LIMIT ON THE
SCOPE OF EMERGENCY POWERS. AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOODBRIDGE
CALIFORNIA WITH THE MAJORITY OF
STATES THAT ALREADY HAVE
EXPLICIT STATUTE SPECIFYING THAT
EMERGENCY POWERS ARETO BE USED
TO RESPOND TO CONDITIONS RELATED
TO AN EMERGENCY. THE OBJECTIVE
IS TO MAINTAIN CLEAR GUIDANCE
UNDER THE EMERGENCY POWERS
STATUTE BY CODIFYING IN THE
ASSUMPTION THAT WE HAVE OPERATED
UNDER THUS FAR. IT IS COMMON
PRACTICE FOR ANY DILIGENT
GOVERNING BODY TO USE FORESIGHT
TO ADDRESS AMBIGUITY OR WEAKNESS
IN THE LAW LIKEWISE THIS BILL
FOLLOWS IN THE SPIRIT OF GOODEN
DILIGENT GOVERNANCE THIS BILL
PASSED THROUGH COMMITTEE WITHOUT
ANY OBJECTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SEYARTO SENIOR MEMBERS
WISH TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE
BILL CLERK WILL OPEN THE- DESIRE
TO GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO THE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES IS FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO BILLS PASSED. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY NINE THROUGH NINETY
TWO. WE WILL GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR THIS IS
H. R. EIGHTY SEVEN FOR KOREAN
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PROBLEM RELATIVE
TO TIME OF DYSKINESIA AWARENESS
WEEK. SERVICE MAY PRESENT YOUR
DESK THANK YOU. MISTER SPEAKER.
HOLD THE MICROPHONE THIS WAY
THANK YOU. UP MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MANY PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
CHRONIC MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE
TREATMENT WITH MEDICATIONS THAT
WORK AS DOPAMINE RECEPTOR
BLOCKING AGENTS INCLUDING ANTI
PSYCHOTICS WHILE ONGOING
TREATMENT WITH THESE MEDICATIONS
CAN BE VERY HELPFUL AND EVEN
LIFESAVING UNFORTUNATELY FOR
SOME IT CAN ALSO LEAD TO HEART
OF DYSKINESIA OR- T. D. TD IS A
MOVEMENT DISORDER THAT IS
CHARACTERIZED BY RANDOM
INVOLUNTARY AND UNCONTROLLED
MOVEMENTS. OF DIFFERENT MUSCLES
IN THE FACE TRUNK AND
EXTREMITIES TD CAN DEVELOP
MONTHS YEARS OR DECADES AFTER
PERSON STARTS TAKING MEDICATION
AND EVEN AFTER THEY HAVE
DISCONTINUED USE OF THOSE
MEDICATIONS NOT EVERYONE WHO
TAKES THESE KINDS OF MEDICATIONS
DEVELOPS TD. BUT IF IT DEVELOPS
IT IS OFTEN PERMANENT. STUDIES
SUGGEST THAT THE OVERALL RISK OF
DEVELOPING TD FOLLOWING
PROLONGED EXPOSURE TO THESE
DRUGS IS BETWEEN TEN AND THIRTY
PERCENT. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
SUFFER FROM TD. YEARS OF
RESEARCH HAVE RESULTED IN
SCIENTIFIC BREAKTHROUGHS OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WITH NEW
TREATMENTS FOR CHENEY APPROVED
BY THE US FDA. TEDIOUS OFTEN ARE
RECOGNIZED IN PATIENTS SUFFERING
FROM THE ILLNESS ARE COMMONLY
MIS DIAGNOSED. JIM TO TAKE THESE
KINDS OF MEDICATIONS SHOULD BE
REGULARLY EVALUATED BY THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
THAT ANY SIDES OF TD. ARE
RECOGNIZED MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON. THE H. R.
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN. SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION MISTER MALONE WHICH
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS. THANKS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. CO AUTHORS. ALL
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
MEMBERS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON H.
R. EIGHTY SEVEN. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
CO AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICEMAIL ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSING NAME
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE AND PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS NINETY FOUR THREE ONE
HUNDRED BRINGING US TO FILE AND
ONE A ONE EIGHTY NINETEEN OH
NINE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
NINETEEN OH NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN ACCLIMATED
VEHICLES CENTER FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IN HONOR OF BIKE MONTH I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN
NO KNOWN MY NINETEEN OH NINE MY
ON THE BIKE BILL TO HELP CLEAR
THE BUMPS IN THE ROAD FOR
CYCLISTS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL MAKES SEVERAL CHANGES TO
OUR RULES OF THE ROAD TO ENHANCE
SAFETY FOR CYCLISTS. NO ONE HAS
FLOWN OFF THE HANDLE IN
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT IS WELL
SPOKEN FOR. THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH KNOWING
YANKING OUR CHAIN. IT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION THE SIERRA
CLUB AND MOVE LA. PLEASE RING IN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SO WE
CAN COAST DOWNHILL FROM HERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
BACK AROUND TO US. SENIOR
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE BILL THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. WE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES ISER FORTY EAT KNOWS
ELEVEN THE BILL IS PASSED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. THIS IS MISSOURI
WINS AB. TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO
AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AN APPLICANT'S INFORMATION
PRIVACY MISSOURI. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS MORE EASILY IDENTIFY
INTERNET OF THINGS OR I O. T.
DEVICES BY ENCOURAGING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND ADOPTION OF
CONSUMER FRIENDLY CYBER SECURITY
LABELS THIS BUILDS ON MY- TO
SECURITY LAW FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHICH RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR WENT. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ESERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
TO VOTE. BURKE WILL. CLOSE ROLL
INTO THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY FIVE.
THOSE ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX.
MISTER WARDS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
ACCOLADE IN HOUSING MISTER MOORE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
WHILE PUBLIC ACQUISITION OF
HOUSING CAN BE A BENEFICIAL TOOL
TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE CURRENT
USE OF THIS MODEL BY JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES FOR AND OUR
FOR PROFIT PARTNERS FAILS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC BENEFIT
COMMENSURATE WITH THE PUBLIC
SUBSIDY THE DOZENS OF
TRANSACTIONS THAT OCCURRED TODAY
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO FIRM
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS.
OPERANDS THAT REMAIN ABOVE THE
MARKET AVERAGE PAYOUT EXORBITANT
FEES TO INVESTORS ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY MONITORED BY A PUBLIC
ENTITY SO THIS BILL EIGHTEEN
FIFTY CENTS A MINIMUM STANDARD
OF OWNERSHIP FOR WHEN PUBLIC
ENTITIES REQUIRE MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING TO ENSURE THAT FUTURE
TRANSACTIONS ARE EQUITABLE FOR
TENANTS THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
IN OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO
LOSE PROPERTY TAX REVENUES THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOWED GPAS
AND FOR PRIVATE INTEREST TO
ENTER INTO MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
AGREEMENTS WHICH WILL ALSO
SECURE AFFORDABLE AND MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING FOR THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE. THANK WAR SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK BELOW FOR THE ROLE. SORRY
BOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS MOVING AHEAD OF
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE THIS IS
MR WARD'S AB. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SEVEN. AND THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARP
BACK LETTING TRANSPORTATION. THE
SHORT YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK YOU
AGAIN MR SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN SEEKS
TO ALIGN THE GOVERNING STATUTES
OF THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS ORIGINALLY PUT IN
PLACE BY SB SEVENTEEN OH THREE
WITH ITS CURRENT ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AS MANDATED BY
STATE LAW. AND CLARIFIES THAT
SANDAG HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PLANNING GOALS
FOR PROJECT DEVELOPMENT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW SANDAG TO
LEVERAGE THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
ACHIEVE ITS SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY GOALS
IMPLEMENT ITS ROBUST HABITAT
CONSERVATION VISION AND STORM
WATER RESILIENCE PLAN AS
OUTLINED IN ITS RECENTLY
APPROVED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL PLAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER. THANK IS FORCING A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO THEM. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI VOTE I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
ARE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE OH TWO THROUGH ONE OH
FOUR.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND OTHERS AND I PLAYED
IN THE WATER MR GARCIA. THANK
YOU SPEAKER MR DOLL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT THIS BILL THAT
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
INDIAN LANDS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE
ROLE TYLER HIGHS SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE OF SIX. ALL THE
WAY THROUGH. ONE SIXTY. THAT'S
ONE OF THE SIX THROUGH ONE
SIXTEEN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN. AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY THREE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH NECKLACE IN THE
<c.green>ULTURE RESOURCES. THIS</c>
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA COAST COMMISSION
TO REQUIRE COASTAL DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT APPLICANTS TO WEAR
FEASIBLE INCLUDING THEIR
PLANNING AND DESIGN OF A PUBLIC
PROJECT. HOW THEY PLAN TO
BUILDER CONTRIBUTE PROMOTING
BLUE CARBON PROJECTS THE BILL
DEFINES BLUE CARBON PROJECT TO
MEAN THE CREATION AND
RESTORATION OF COLD COASTAL
WETLANDS INTERTITLE OR MARINE
HABITATS OR ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO HELP FOR
SEAGRASSES WHAT ONCE THE CAPTURE
CARBON. APPLIES TO ALL PROJECTS
THAT IMPACT AREAS OF COASTLINE
WITH THE NEXUS TO BLUE CARBON
I'M NOT JUST PUBLIC PROJECTS IN
GENERAL BUT TO EXPAND POTENTIAL
INVESTMENTS IN LOW CARBON.
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
REQUIRE APPLICATIONS TO MITIGATE
GHG EMISSIONS VIA PUT BLUE
CARBON PROJECTS THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF A TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT IN NORTH COUNTY SAN
DIEGO AND MY DISTRICT WHERE THE
WIDENING OF THE I. FIVE FREEWAY
LANES ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY RESIDENTS IN REGARDS THE
IMPACTS. OF WILDLIFE LIVING IN
SIX COASTAL LAGOON THIRTY TWO
ACRES OF WETLANDS AND SEVENTY
FOUR ACRES OF COASTAL SAGE.
DURING THE COURSE OF PERMITTING
PROCESS THE COASTAL COMMISSION
APPROVED THE PROJECT WITH
IMPROVEMENTS RELATE TO ENHANCE
FOR ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
HABITATS. THIS INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO MITIGATE IMPACTS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES CAN BE
REPLICATED TO BUILD OR RESTORE
BLUE CARBON SINKS LOW CARBON IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE YET
OVERLOOKED METHOD FOR LONG TERM
SEQUESTRATION AND STORAGE OF
CARBON. BLUE CARBON ECOSYSTEMS
ONLY PREVENT CLIMATE CHANGE THEY
ALSO PROTECT COSTA COMMITTEES
FROM ITS HARMFUL IMPACT SUCH AS
RISING SEAS AND FLOODING AND TO
PROVIDE IMPORTANT HABITATS FOR
MARINE LIFE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
FOR. SEEING THEIR DISCUSS DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL.
SERVER ALL MEMBERS FOR THEIR
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRED ABOUT. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTEEN
THROUGH ONE TWENTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN. BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR. THIS IS MR
STONE'S ACR. ONE SIXTY NINE AND
THE CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO SEE ON
OUR AWARENESS WEEK. MISTER STARR
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ACR ONE SIXTY NINE DECLARES
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND OF THIS
YEAR AS SEA WATER AWARENESS WEEK
AS YOU NO SEA OTTERS ARE A
KEYSTONE SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND- I CONIC OF OUR COSTA IN
OUR- COASTAL HABITATS. THIS IS
THE E. AND AWARENESS ISSUE THAT
WILL COINCIDE WITH THE FIRST
ATER CAMP THAT'S BEEN DONE AND
PROBABLY ALMOST A DECADE LAST
OUT ACCOUNT SHOWED ONLY ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE ALMOST WIPED FROM
EXTINCTION. NOT THAT LONG AGO
HUNDRED YEARS OR SO AGO THE
POPULATION HAS SLOWLY BEEN
COMING BACK AND HAS NOT REALLY
GROWN THAT MUCH IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES THIS SEA OTTER
AWARENESS WEEK WILL GIVE
SCIENTISTS AND RESEARCHERS AND-EDUCATIONAL STUDENTS THE ABILITY
TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC. AND RAISE
AWARENESS AND LOOK AT WHAT
OTHERS DO FOR OUR HABITATS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK NATALIE XIN
AND INTERNET OUR OFFICE THIS
YEAR WHO'S DONE ALL THE LEG WORK
ON THIS RESOLUTION I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES AN ASSET THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISTER STELLA
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MR
STARR IS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
WELL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. ACR ONE SEVENTY TWO BY
MISTER COOPER AND THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER RELATIVE
TO PEACE OFFICERS MISTER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY IS
THE FORTY FOURTH ANNUAL
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL CEREMONY. IT'S A TIME
EVERY YEAR WE CAN PAY TRIBUTE TO
THE FALLEN OFFICERS WHO PAID THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IF MY
COLLEAGUES IT TOOK TIME OUT OF
THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES TO ATTEND
THIS MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE FAMILIES THIS YEAR
REMEMBER THIRTY SIX OF OUR BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN WILL BE
MEMORIALIZED ON THE PEACE
OFFICERS MONUMENT. THE ALSO WE
ARE TODAY COME FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA THE SERVICE SIXTEEN
CITIES SIXTEEN COUNTIES IF
FORGET THEIR LIVES IN STATE
SERVICE ALSO TIME TO OTHER
FAMILIES THE MANY WIVES HUSBANDS
CHILDREN PARENTS GRANDPARENTS
AND OTHER FAMILY AND FRIENDS BUT
ALSO GAVE SO THE PEACE OFFICER
TO PROTECT. HE TOOK THE OATH TO
ALSO PROTECT AND SERVE WITH
REFERENCING GRATITUDE LET US
NEVER FORGET HILTON SACRIFICE
THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES GAVE US
TO KEEP ALL OF US SAFE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND REQUEST TO BE OPEN FOR.
THE LAWYERS. THANK YOU MISS
COOPER MR LACKEY YOUR RECOGNIZE. YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I JUST WANTED TO REALLY
QUICKLY JUST SAY THAT- I
APPRECIATE GREATLY THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YES SACRIFICE THAT-
MANY OFFICERS MAKE UNFORTUNATELY
TOO MANY ACTUALLY PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE. YOU KNOW I
WORKED IN A PART OF THE OF THE
STATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL IN AN OFFICE THAT- WAS
VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT THEY
NEVER LOST AN OFFICER IN THE
LINE OF DUTY. AND UNFORTUNATELY
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
LOST OUR FIRST ONE WEEK
KNOWLEDGE THEN TODAY IS NAMES
AND YOUR ANALYSIS. AND- PRETTY
HEARTBREAKING COME FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT FAMILY HIS MOTHER
WORKED. WITH ME MANY YEAR AS
FATHER WAS- LAPD WAS STILL AS
LAPD MOTORCYCLE OFFICER HIS
BROTHER. AS A WATER OFFICER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
THEY ALL KNOW THE DANGER YET
THEY STILL CONTINUE. TO MAKE THE
SACRIFICE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
IN AND THEY ALL HAVE A SERVANT'S
HEART SO I THANK YOU ALL FOR A
KNOWLEDGE IN THE SERVANT'S HEART
THAT IS- DEMONSTRATED ON A DAILY
BASIS BY OUR PEACE OFFICERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR LACKEY.
MISTER ROBERTS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I'M THANK
YOU MISTER- SPEAKER. CERTAINLY
TODAY IS A SOLEMN DAY FOR US TO
REMEMBER THOSE THAT GAVE THEIR
LIVES FOR US TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO- STAND UP AND RECOGNISE
AND OFFER PRAYERS TO THE
FAMILIES EVERY DAY OF THE YEAR-
THAT GOES ON BECAUSE- EVERY DAY
THEY GO ON WITH THE MEMORY. OF A
LOVED ONE THAT PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE FOR YOU AND ME TO BE
HERE TODAY AND KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. WE CONTINUE TO
STAND WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS AND
SAMBAR INO COUNTY- MAKING SURE
THAT THE FAMILIES OF THE VAKIT
DEPUTY VAKA AND DEPUTY CON TO
NOT ALL THAT THIS LEGISLATURE-
STANDS WITH THEM EVERY DAY THEY
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD ALONG
WITH ALL FAMILIES THAT LOST
SOMEONE- THROUGHOUT THIS
MEMORIAL IN AGAIN RECOGNIZING
THEM AND KEEPING THEM UP IN
PRAYER. EVERY DAY OF THE YEAR
NOT JUST ONE DAY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS
ROSS MS VALLADARES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU AND MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION
THAT COMMEMORATES THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES IN THE LINE OF DUTY. THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A HARDER TIME TO
BE A PEACE OFFICER THAN TODAY WE
ASK THE WORLD OF THESE BRAVE MEN
AND WOMEN AND THEY GIVE IT THEIR
ALL. I'M REMINDED OF A
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD WITH A
FRIEND OF A FRIEND AND WIFE OF A
PEACE OFFICER A FEW WEEKS AGO I
ASKED HER HOW SHE DEALT WITH THE
BURDEN FOR SO LONG SHE REPLIED.
IT WAS EASY I LOOKED AT HER SHE
SAID THAT THEY HAD ONE RULE NO
MATTER WHERE HE WAS HE WOULD
CALL ME AT THE SAME HOUR EVERY
NIGHT WITHOUT FAIL SOMETIMES
FROM A BUSH SOMETIMES JUST A
QUICK. I CAN'T TALK. MANY PEACE
OFFICERS LIVE IN FEAR MEET MANY
PEACE OFFICERS FAMILIES LIVE IN
FEAR OF THAT CALL. MY HUSBAND
AND HIS FAMILY RECEIVED A CALL
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AFTER
HIS FATHER MY WONDERFUL FATHER
IN LAW EARL VALLADARES AN LAPD
DETECTIVE WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD
DURING THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
NORTH HOLLYWOOD SHOOTOUT. YOU'D
BE FINE BUT THAT IS NOT ALWAYS
THE CASE FOR TOO MANY PEACE
OFFICERS AND THEIR FAMILIES. ONE
SUCH OFFICER WAS DAVID MARCH WHO
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO TWENTY
YEARS AGO THIS WEEK LOST HIS
LIFE AFTER BEING AMBUSHED DURING
A TRAFFIC STOP. HE WAS A
DETERMINED AND WONDERFUL
PROTECTOR OF HIS COMMUNITY. I
DIDN'T KNOW DAVE BUT WE HAVE
MANY MUTUAL FRIENDS I'M STILL
TALK ABOUT HIM TODAY AND MORE IN
THIS TRAGEDY. THIS LOSS IS STILL
FELT THROUGHOUT MY COMMUNITY
TODAY. HIS NAME IS ENROLLED ON
CALIFORNIA'S PEACE OFFICER
MEMORIAL MONUMENT SO THAT OUR
STATE NEVER FORGET THE SACRIFICE
HE MADE. IT IS ENTIRELY FITTING
THAT OUR STATE HONOR THE
SACRIFICES OF THESE MEN AND
WOMEN THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PUTTING SERVICE ABOVE SELF
REGARDLESS OF HOW PERILOUS THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. PROVES THAT THEIR
COURAGE AND THEIR DEDICATION
EXEMPLIFIES THE VERY BEST OF OUR
STATE I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU HIS FATHER'S. MR BE APPROVED
BY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FIGURE
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE REMEMBER OF
OUR FALLEN PEACE OFFICER WHO
MADE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE
SACRIFICE TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE LAST YEAR STOCKTON LOST A
GREAT OFFICER IN AND OUTSTANDING
MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY JIMMY
AND- WHO WAS MURDERED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY YOU'RE RESPONDING
TO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL.
ALMOST A YEAR AGO TODAY. JIMMY
WAS A SIX YEAR BAN VETERAN OF
THE STOCKTON POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND A LOVING SON FATHER AND
HUSBAND. LIKE MANY PEACE PEACE
OFFICERS HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO PUT OTHERS FIRST
AND FOUR KEY KEEP A DEEP LOVE OF
THIS COMMUNITY M. HAD THE HIS
COMMUNITY. NUMBER ONE AT IT AS
HIS RESPONSIBILITY. BOB IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT WE HONOR
HIM TODAY AND ALL THOSE WHO GAVE
THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS. MAY THEY REST IN
PEACE. THANK YOU THIS REPORT TO
A- MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU HAS BECOME
MEMBERS AYE AYE TO RISE- TO
SOLEMNLY- SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION
I HAVE BEEN THINKING TODAY A BIT
ABOUT THE TERM HERO. WE THROW
THAT TERM AROUND A LOT THESE
DAYS SOMETIMES WHEN SOMEONE IN A
BASKETBALL GAME SHOOTS A THREE
POINTER AT THE TOP OF THE KEY
AND PUSH. THE BUZZER GOES OFF
AND THEY WIN AND THAT'S ROIC
IT'S. BUT HEROISM IS WHAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE
HONORING TODAY. DO EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND ESPECIALLY UPON THE DAY
THEY WERE SWORN IN. BECAUSE THEY
RAISED THEIR RIGHT HAND. AND
THEY SWORE TO PRESERVE PROTECT
AND TO SERVE. KNOWING FULL WELL
IT MIGHT VERY WELL COST THEM THE
LAST FULL MEASURE OF DEVOTION.
THAT'S HEROISM I AM ALSO
THINKING TODAY ABOUT THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE OFFICERS WHO
EVERY DAY. THEY GO ON PATROL ON
OUR BEHALF AND THE FAMILIES ARE
LEFT TO HOPE AND PRAY THAT WHEN
THE SHIFT IS OVER THEY COME BACK
HOME SAFE AND SOUND. YES THE
OFFICER WHERE'S THE BADGE BUT IT
IS THE FAMILY THAT CARRIES THE
WEIGHT. AND SO LET US REMEMBER
THEM AS WELL AS THOSE WHO SERVE
US. BECAUSE IT TOUCHES THEIR
FAMILY THEIR LOVED ONES AS THEY
SERVE OUR FAMILIES AND OUR LOVED
ONES. AND SO THIS BODY IS
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR SERVICE. WE
RISING UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. AND REMIND OURSELVES
WE WILL NEVER EVER FORGET WAT
THEY DO FOR US. AND WE WILL
ALWAYS BE GRATEFUL FOR THE FACT
THERE ARE HEROES AMONG US.
FAMOUS PATTERSON MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM
ELK GROVE TO BRING THIS ACR
WANTS ME TO FORD YOU KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT BEING IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ESPECIALLY A PARENT
OF AN OFFICER AS YOU KNOW MY SON
HAS BEEN ON THE PARMER FOR OVER
TEN YEARS AND SEEN THE FAMILIES-
THIS MORNING AT THE MEMORIAL
JUST RINGS TO HOME THAT
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY. I WOULD NEVER
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THAT PHONE CALL THAT MY SON
DIDN'T RETURN HOME AFTER IS HIS
SHIFT BECAUSE AS WE SEE THERE IS
EVIL IN THIS WORLD EVIL IN THE
STATE AND A LOT OF. THINGS THAT
GO ON IN OF THESE OFFICERS RUN
TOWARD THAT EVIL ARE THERE THAT
ARE PROTECT US WHILE WE'RE
RUNNING AWAY SO I JUST WANT TO
STAND. HERE IN SOLIDARITY WITH.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE. TO
SUPPORT THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FOR THE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT THAT THEY DO THEIR JOBS.
PROTECTING US IN THE TIME A
NEED. AND LET'S ALWAYS REMEMBER
THEM THE FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
FOR ALL THE SACRIFICES THEY PAID
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ MISS RHYS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I TO RISE I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OUTGROW FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION. I
THINK OF THE INLAND EMPIRE HAD.
TO BIGGER SHARE OF THE FALLEN
OFFICERS. SERGEANT STEVEN LIKE
ON C. H. P. FROM RIVERSIDE
OFFICER ANDRE MARIE'S MORE A
JUNIOR C. H. P. RIVERSIDE.
DEPUTY TERREL YOUNG RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S SERGEANT HARRY
COHN RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
OFFICER WHO YOUR BEST ON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT. SERGEANT DOMINICK
BACA EMITIDO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT DETECTIVE ARMADO CON
TO SENATOR DINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN HIS COMMENTS TODAY REMINDED
THE FAMILIES THAT. THEIR HERO
WAS OUR HERO I THINK WE SHOULD
REMEMBER THAT ALWAYS THAT THEY
ARE OUR HEROES COMMISSION TO
READ. WITHOUT OBJECTION I'D LIKE
TO READ JUST THE FIRST AND THE
LAST STANZA FROM THE MONUMENT.
SAYS I NEVER DREAMED IT WOULD BE
ME MY NAME FOR ALL ETERNITY
RECORDED HERE AT THIS HALLOWED
PLACE. ALAS MY NAME NO MORE MY
FACE. I NEVER DREAMED IT WOULD
BE ME I WOULD HAVE A HEART AND
BENDED KNEE. I ASK FOR ALL HERE
FROM THE PAST DEAR GOD LET MY
NAME BE THE LAST. THANK YOU MS
REYES. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. MISTER
COOPER HAS ASSET THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ON ACR. ONE
SEVENTY TWO. CLERK WILL CLOSE
RATHER SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED TO SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. AND THE CLERK WILL
READ THE NAMES RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION. HE HONORED OFFICERS
INCLUDE DETECTIVE ARE MONDO
CANTU SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH NOVEMBER EIGHTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE OFFICER HOW
MENDER GREAT WALL GOT POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH AUGUST
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
DEPUTY PHILIP CAMPUS KERN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE END OF WATCH
JULY TWENTY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE SERGEANT DOMINICK
BACA SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND OF
WATCH MAY THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE OFFICER
JIMMY AND STOCKTON POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH MAY
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. DETECTIVE LOOK UP IN A
DADDY SAN LUIS OBISPO POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH MAY
TENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
OFFICER JOSE AND ZORA LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH MAY THIRD TWO THOUSAND
MARCH THIRD TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. DEPUTY THOMAS J. ALBANY'S
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE SERGEANT RICHARD P. BROWN
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. DEPUTY ADAM
SANDLER GIPSON SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND WATCH
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE OFFICER ANGEL DELA
FUENTE FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND OF WATCH DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
OFFICER ANDY ORNELAS CHP
ANTELOPE VALLEY AREA END OF
WATCH DECEMBER SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICER JULIO BELL TRAN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH NOVEMBER
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
SERGEANT HARRY M. COLON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH OCTOBER
EIGHTEENTH. TWENTY TWENTY
DETECTIVE JOSE C. MARA FRESNO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND OF
WATCH SEPTEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICER VALENTYN MARTINEZ
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND OF WATCH JULY TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY. SERGEANT DAMON
CHRISTOPHER GUTS WILLER SENT
SANTA CRUZ SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND
OF WATCH JUNE SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICER DANIEL G. WALTERS
SAN DIEGO POLICE DEPARTMENT END
OF WATCH. APRIL TWENTY THIRD TO
THE TO. THIRTY TO WROTE ON YOUNG
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHE TO. END OF
WATCH ABLE SO TWENTY TWENTY
DETECTIVE MARY LOU HERNANDEZ
ARMOR SANTA ROSA POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND OF WATCH MARCH
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
OFFICER ELMER JONATHAN D. AS THE
MORE POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH NOVEMBER SECOND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DEPUTY BRIAN
DAVID ISHMAEL EL DORADO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND WATCH
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. OFFICER ANDRE
MAURICE MOORE JUNIOR C. H. P.
RIVERSIDE AREA END OF WATCH
AUGUST TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OFFICE OF TERROR
CRISTINA O'SULLIVAN SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH
JUNE NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SERGEANT STEVEN L. THE
CONE C. H. P. RIVER AREA IN OF
WATCH APRIL SIX TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OFFICER NATALIE BECKY
CORONA DAVIS POLICE DEPARTMENT
END OF WATCH JANUARY TENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. OFFICER TO
CEO CARRARESE GARDENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
OFFICER ARE MONDO GALLAGHER
JUNIOR. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
END OF WATCH SEPTEMBER
FOURTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. FALLEN OFFICERS FROM
THE DISTANT PAST INCLUDE DEPUTY
WILLIAM R. JOHNSON CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE END OF
WATCH JULY THIRTY FIRST EIGHTEEN
FIFTY TWO. MARSHAL ROAD OFF BONE
ANAHEIM POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH OCTOBER SECOND EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SIX DEPUTY DANIEL TODD
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN TEN.
CONSTABLE WARREN P. WILLARD
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
AND OF WATCH MARCH TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN TWELVE. DEPUTY GALAMBOS
WAY LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTEEN
DEPUTY CONSTABLE LEROY H. TRIP.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH APRIL
TENTH NINETEEN SIXTEEN MARSHALL
JAMES WEST NEEDLES PLEASE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH. JULY
SIXTH NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE IF
AND HARRY TO. NEEDLES POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN THE WATCH JUNE
TENTH. NINETEEN FIVE. MEMBERS
PLEASE RISE FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE AS WE HONOR THESE
OFFICERS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
EVERS BACK ON THE FILE. THIS IS.
FILE ITEM. ONE TWENTY SIX ACR
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN RELATIVE TO DONATE
LIFE DMB PARTNERSHIP MONTH
MISSOURI. THANK YOU SPEAKER ACR
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PROCLAIMS THE
MONTH OF APRIL AS DONATE LIFE
DMV MONTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT EVERY TEN
MINUTES ONE PERSON WILL BE ADDED
TO THE NATIONAL ORGAN TRANSPLANT
WAITING LIST EVERY DAY TWENTY
TWO PEOPLE WILL DIE BECAUSE A
LIFE SAVING ORGAN IS NOT
AVAILABLE. TODAY OVER TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
WAITING FOR A LIFESAVING
TRANSPLANT IN JULY TWO THOUSAND
SIX THE DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA
REGISTRY IN THE DMV BEGAN A
PARTNERSHIP CREATING AN
ELECTRONIC DATABASE OF THE
STATE'S REGISTERED. DONORS
REPLACING THE PINK DOT STICKERS
AND DONOR CARDS NEARLY SIXTEEN
YEARS LATER THEY HAVE REACHED
MORE THAN SEVENTEEN MILLION
REGISTERED DONORS IN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
APRIL TWENTY. TWENTY TWO AS
DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA DMV MONTH
AND IF YOU HAVE NOT YET
REGISTERED PLEASE CONSTITUENCY I
RESPECT. FOR YOUR RIVALS. THANK
YOU MISSOURI SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION WOULD
YOU LIKE A PERSONAL TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON A
C. R. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. WELL
CLOSER ROLE THERE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
S. HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS
WITH US. IN THE CHAMBER IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A C. R. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE WELCOME DMV
DIRECTOR STEVE GORDON. WELCOME
MR GORDON.
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ACR ONE EIGHTY
FIVE I MISS QUIRK-SILVA COOKERY
. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
RELATIVE TO A RAP AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH MISS QUIRK-SILVA
. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT ACR ONE EIGHTY
FIVE ARAB AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH ACR ONE EIGHTY FIVE
CELEBRATES AND RECOGNIZES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY ARAB
AMERICANS. ARAB AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN RICH THE FABRIC OF OUR
STATE AND NATION WITH THEIR MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS AND INNOVATION
MEDICINE LAW BUSINESS EDUCATION
TECHNOLOGY. AND MILITARY THE
HISTORY OF THE ARAB AMERICAN
COMMUNITY GOES BACK TO THE EARLY
DAYS OF OUR NATION'S INCEPTION
AND IS DEEPLY WOVEN INTO OUR
DIVERSE TAPESTRY. IT IS ON HONOR
TO CELEBRATE THEIR RICH CULTURE
AND TRADITIONS WE MUST ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY ERROR ARAB
AMERICANS CONTINUE TO BE HARMED
BY DISCRIMINATION BIAS AND
VIOLENCE. I AM PROUD TO HAVE
LITTLE ARABIA IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH IS A CULTURAL AND BUSINESS
DESTINATION FOR ARAB AMERICANS
OF DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS WHO ENJOY
ARAB FOOD AND CULTURE. THE
PROFOUND AND SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS AND HERITAGE OF
ARAB AMERICANS HAVE HELPED TO
BUILD A BETTER STATE AND NATION
MEMBERS PLEASE RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ARAB AMERICAN. EACH MONTH.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISS
QUIRK-SILVA YOU WOULD LIKE TO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. YES
RIGHT THANK YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA
THIS ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO%
AUTHORS CLIP OF THE ROCK. THIS
IS CO AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL THERE
SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADAM
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE
ARE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CITY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
. SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO AND OTHERS NOT HOLDING A
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- LETTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY. ALL
MEMBERS OF. ZERO CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF I. SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS
ADOPTED AND CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT OH
ZERO.
CORKERY. MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE A
BILL ON CALL.
WE DO HAVE ONE REMAINING ITEM ON
CALL. A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS WE HAVE TO COMMITTEE
HEARINGS THIS AFTERNOON. BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ONE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SIX. MEMBERS A REMINDER THAT
TOMORROW AT TEN AM WILL BE
SWEARING IN OUR NEWEST MEMBER
MISTER MATT HANEY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. THAT WILL OCCUR IN
THIS CHAMBER AT TEN AM. TOMORROW.
MR LEVINE WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE
SIR LIKE TO LIFT THE CALL CLOSE
THE COST FOR RECONSIDERATION.
WE'RE GOING TO LIVE CALL ON MISS
LEVIN'S ADAM THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE CLERK POSTS. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE. WELL
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL DIVERT
EYES EIGHTEEN NEWS EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE FAILS AND MISSED LEVINE
NO RECONSIDER YES THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL IS
STILL IN PLACE. WE WILL MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. MISTER SPEAKER HAS A
GERMAN IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS TIME.
QUORUM CALL IS STILL IN PLACE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS TODAY ASKED THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE OPT IN
HONOR OF THE YOUNG POLICE
OFFICER DETECTIVE ALEXIS
GONZALEZ IT'S REMARKABLE HOW
MUCH OF AN IMPRESSION HE MADE ON
HIS DEPARTMENT ANALYST COMMUNITY
IN JUST A FEW A FEW SHORT YEARS.
TERRAKOM OF THE CHIEF OF THE
SOUTH GATE POLICE DEPARTMENT
SAID DETECTIVES GONZALEZ WAS A
SHINING STAR IN ORGANIZATION AND
HIS INFECTIOUS SMILE WAS
NOTICEABLE FROM MILES AWAY MY
STAFF AND I DID NOT HAVE TO SEE
IT FROM A MILLION MILES AWAY WE
INTERACTED WITH THEM QUITE OFTEN
WE'RE ABLE TO INTERACT WITH
THEM- QUITE RECENTLY- ARE ONE OF
OUR RECENT ARTS FESTIVALS IN THE
DISTRICT. DETECTIVE GONZALEZ WAS
BORN AND RAISED SOUTHGATE AND
JOINED THE DEPARTMENT AS AN
EXPLORER IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN QUICKLY RISING TO THE
RANKS OF CAPTAIN HE CONTINUALLY
PURSUED HIS GOAL OF SERVING THIS
CITY BECOMING AN OFFICER IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
LAST YEAR HE WAS PROMOTED TO
DETECTIVE. LAKE MONTH ALEXIS THE
AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN DIED AFTER
AN OFF DUTY SINGLE CAR MOTOR
VEHICLE COLLISION. HE LEAVES
BEHIND HIS PARENTS AND TWO
BROTHERS. THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
LOSS TO THE COMMUNITY. AND JUST
LAST FAMILY IN A PERSONAL LOSS
TO THE SOUTH GATE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND TO MY DISTRICT
OFFICE. I ASKED WE INJURED TODAY
IN THE MEMORY OF A LEXUS
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MAY THIRD CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY FOURTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE
AM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SINGER NO FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS REYES MOVES. MS VALLADARES
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MAY
FIFTH AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM
CALL IS NOW LIFTED.
VALIDATOR IS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
S. TO OBTAIN. CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VELADERO SYSTEM PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN FIFTY I TO NOT LOADING.